speaking of space um
elon
what did he do
besides like deceive the entire sec yeah
i don't know so he he you know we talked
about it last week he bought a huge
stake in twitter and then said that he
was going to be on the twitter board you
know he the ceo was like hey elon's
going to be on our board
you know welcome yeah like a great you
know much needed voice on the board of
twitter or whatever and they posted a
couple days ago oh psych that's not
actually happening anymore yeah cause
he's uh
he didn't disclose his purchase so now
they had to walk his ass back no but he
still he still
like bought the shares no he still owns
them but i thought that's why he
couldn't be on the board i don't know
there's something about like not being
able to own more than 14 of a company if
you're on the board so people are like
well maybe he wants to buy more
interesting um
and then finally delete hassan's twitter
yes
yes exactly that's all he wants yeah
that's what i like to imagine yeah
horrible ex-boyfriend
i will blackball you
[Laughter]
then he calls jeff and he's like
listen i know we don't see rti
but i have a favorite task
i need you to ban this twitch streamer
did you see
did you you know what i was you probably
didn't see this what
i was on tmz.com this morning yeah i
definitely didn't see this you know i
was like why the [ __ ] did i see this
yeah
jeff bezos and his new wife yeah
went out for a double date with who do
you think
just guess any hollywood couple right
now him and pete yep
nailed it
why
why
why would that be a double date cause
kim and jeff are in their billionaires
group chat
they have a billionaire's group chat
where they talk about these things and
they brag about their young new things
you think that's what it is yeah
definitely yeah maybe and and pete
it's awkward for pete because you know
it's it's a male dominated group we
haven't we haven't solved the the sexism
quality and billionaires problems yeah
right so he is with all the side chicks
or like the new wives
and he's just the only dude yeah but the
you know this dangerous territory
because he's starting to charm them up
right yeah the billionaires are like
hey
kim
keep that i'm gonna put a leash on this
guy jesus i'm gonna [ __ ] this whole
house i love this whole house
this is a wedding it's really down to
love isn't he
yeah of course where do they go to eat
i don't know like
where was it what was it
[Laughter]
looks like it was at jeff's pad
oh jeff's house
oh
okay his pad is bachelor pad nice yeah
but
yeah no how the [ __ ] do they get in
there this these paparazzi man that's
what i'm saying
they just wait outside of his house yeah
i think so god that sucks you ever go to
craigs in west hollywood no yeah we
talked about it how they're always just
kind of there did we talk about that
yeah and didn't they like you know
didn't they like go to fire a photo of
you and they're like eh no no they
didn't they just look at you they go hmm
got it and then we're like should we
walk by again
are you guys sure
i could like whatever i mean like
whatever you want they're like we want
you to move out of the way yeah yeah
cool so you'd get one of me on the
street then or yeah yeah no go ahead go
ahead walk down the street yeah
yeah of course they went on a double
date i just want to know what that
conversation was like yeah that's what
i'm saying i can't even imagine what
they would talk about what they would
damn jeff kind of a big house yeah
that's my that's your beat dave that's
an impression
i don't really know what his voice
sounds like outside my head and then
kim's like
thank you
this is a big house jeff
then jeff's girlfriend is like
tonight at nine robbery taking place
like she's still in reporter mode
who does that
damn
if pete davidson ever goes back to
comedy his special is gonna sound insane
yeah yeah
so kanye's trying to kill me
yeah maybe the first line yeah
uh
turns out my dick is big enough to [ __ ]
kim and
yeah
wasn't big enough for ariana it was
being uh
whatever the hell
yeah there's you know there's some
people that are like just good at like
remaining famous yeah just by being in
the same vicinity just by being talked
about yeah pete obviously right now is
like the best at that for some reason
but the best part is he doesn't even say
anything that's what i mean yeah just
[ __ ] yeah
it's so crazy jeff bezos kanye like just
nuts he knocked them all down yeah only
only thing left from here is like
russian oligarch yeah like
pete and putin yeah oh damn it yeah
that's crazy
you know elon like
went to ukraine or something or like
told them he launched like
um
starling satellites like claiming like
he was gonna provide internet for them
elon yeah and then just never did that
no way really yeah we just like tried to
just insert himself into that is that
true
something like google that
yeah here we go elon musk spacex sent
thousands of starling satellite internet
dishes to ukraine
yeah that's what president says
he could just
he just said that
like it's not like they didn't actually
do it he's not like offering internet or
anything like they just like said that
because no one can actually verify yeah
yeah now they're up there
yeah we uh we don't see them on our
wi-fi list
no we've put them up there yeah they're
not either that's because your computers
suck yeah
if you bought tesla computers you can
connect to our starlink
by the way we're gonna watch the
funniest video
in the bonus we can't watch it in the
free because
uh it's like filled with copyrighted
music but it's elon at the what's the
tesla
conference called gigafest no vidcon
gigachad cyber rodeo
cool man
no that's really cool
i called it a cyber rodeo because uh uh
my stock portfolio is just it's a bull
market for me all day every day
cool man
yeah i can't wait to see that
ass wipe
you